people of the internet retro raking tour
here just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell welcome back to Harry
Potter and the Order of the Phoenix it
says that we only have two tasks
remaining I'm not sure why it says that
because we have quite a bit still left
over here I guess something about we
only have two active at this point but
if you remember in our last episode or
if you weren't here if you're just
jumping into this one I'll catch you up
we talked to Professor Flitwick but
before we can go any further doing that
mini Quest we need to find a textbook
well from what I can tell the game
doesn't really give you any indication
or hint of where that textbook may be
you talk to her miny she doesn't know
she won't help you out and so we're left
with wandering the
castle with the exception though of the
fact that we have a pretty significant
Advantage playing this game in a modern
era and that is you yes you watching
this right now the commenter because
someone commented on our last
video and little bit of back seating
it's all good though this is kind of
back seating you know I'm cool I'm cool
with that kind of back
seating and you guys said that
apparently the book we need is in the
great
hall now also in one of those uh recent
episodes we had a moment where we walked
into the Great Hall and there was a
little cut scene that
played that actually kind of gave us a
hint as to who had the book but I think
what threw me off is when it did that we
were actually on the Quest for Angelina
Johnson discover scoundrel and so I
thought that it was showing us hey
Angelina's in here somewhere if you guys
remember when we were at that part I
kind of walked around looking at all the
different students like are you Angelina
are you Angelina where's
Angelina so I think that is actually
what they were pointing out there so
let's go in here through the entrance
hall if the door will actually
open there he goes
finally to next time are you coming now
remember no camera control she
reading there what's she
[Music]
reading all right Ron giving us the
little hint right
there but still I mean how would you
know like you guys let me know in the
comments the first time you played
through this game I mean I played
through it too many many years ago I
don't remember this part you basically
just have to WAND around reading can I
have a quick
look yes yes of course well that was
obvious yeah completely obvious all
we've got to do now is write the
essay uh oh for goodness sake you'll
have to do your own essays
sometime imagine if you actually had to
write the essay therefore and they and
in
[Music]
conclusion right let's take these essays
back to Professor flip
twick nice so we should just be able to
go here
now Mark Professor Flitwick
again and then I'm hoping this will give
us our first look at a mini Quest
that we do either with the
professor for the professor I'm not
really
sure I promise you guys I did play this
game years ago but I just I'm not sure
why I just can't remember a lot of it
other other than this maybe it's because
you spend so much time wandering this
exact staircase over and over studious
success a healthy mind is an inquisitive
mind all right thank you
Horus there's our boy Flitwick right
there Professor Flitwick we've brought
you the homework you asked for excellent
Miss Granger excellent I'm sure these
will do you all
credit check the Marauders map to see
which tasks you have started wait
that's the charms CL I thought that was
it I thought he just walked off and we
were done all right let's see can we
need a little fire in here Flitwick come
on we can't cast incendio on
that and it looks like they do have some
of the Spells written on there but
they're
just very hard to make out in this
game as you are aware this is an
important year for your studies we shall
be working harder than ever to ensure
that you do yourself Justice let us
begin well Mr poter let us get I'm not
sure why his voice got so much lower and
we will see how many I did not change
anything on my end just so you guys know
something weird about this cut scene
okay press L2 or R2 to change
targets okay wiard Ros wardi leosa wait
what do
you Wingardium Leviosa
[Music]
RTO
redo
okayo
a
AO wait
aoo Depo AO I don't know what he wants
us to AO into
pulso
incendio okay incendio was up down up
down incendio
reducto why is is he testing me on speed
Leos oh dear we get a grade your best
work what would be graded as Dreadful M
excuse me
fedwick what
I feel
attacked why would that be graded as as
Dreadful here to continue your yeah yeah
yeah let's do it again have high
expectations of you Mr Potter I'm going
to pay closer attention this time well
Mr Potter let us get started call out
the charms I want you within the time
liit okay so we do have to be fast
within the time liit does it matter what
we at begins
now wardian levosa Wingardium Leviosa
okay red
redo I don't think it
matters
raro okay so it does spe is all that
hereo and then apparently you do have to
at least be on something that nope
thisio
redo oh come on there we
go
not going to get a dreadful this time a
consumate example of cting Mr bter aied
exceeds expectations good work Mr I'm
still disappointed that it's not an O
but you know what I'll take the exceeds
expectations especially after we got a
dreadful to start like come on
Flitwick I'm going to blame his
directions on there he was not specific
enough actually I probably just didn't
read closely enough it did in fact
mention the time limit okay so Flitwick
is now gone from here Dean is the one
with the gargoyle so we have to be on
the lookout for those Padma and
prati I can't remember those either but
I think those are the only two so Dean
and the ptil twins those are the only
students we have left so let's go ahead
and do the mini quest with mogle cuz
we're pretty close to that
one this episode can be focused on all
of our assignments here at least at the
start we'll see how fast we're able to
complete
them okay so can we head this way
nope yeah this studious portra used
quite a bit right here you may pass Mr
Potter all right down we go
and into another portrait pass friend to
Hufflepuff friend to
Hufflepuff yes we are indeed a friend
huffle
puff all right into the Transfiguration
Courtyard now I'm trying to picture in
the layout of hogwart's Legacy it was
wasn't it this isn't it that building
right there or excuse me that
room or it might just be the opposite
side here of what I was picturing I
think there's yeah there's
meon think there's a
tking I did it again man I did that in
the last episode talking talking
gargoyle get lost Potter I'm not I'm not
even talking to you bro not even trying
to talk to you Potter Weasley Miss
Granger I have a little task for you by
you I mean gryffindor's two new prefects
yes Professor I am I'm standing here in
expectation of a group of firste boys
arriving for detention however by all
reports they're hiding in the Divination
pleas tell to come here please tell them
to come here immediately of course
Professor
mcgonagal all right so divination Tower
is where they're
located let's see divination there we
go
all right now they did mention gargoyles
in the
area which this is originally where we I
mean I don't think that's you was
talking gargoyle you normally talk to
ones that God speak ially talk to gargo
or should imagine many gargoyles are
grateful for that thanks for talking to
us let's go she didn't seem very happy
that's one gargoyle
found I mean am I wrong guys that that's
not a gargoyle is it
unless I have a different understanding
of
gargo first
is all you did was fight a Troll save an
illegal dragon and ignore the advice of
Professor Dumbledore so Harry could
fight Professor qul let's go to the
Divination Tower that's kind of cool I
like little uh little conversations like
that all right well now that we know
that the the little winged Boors are
what they mean by the G egg may your
courage
hold go to be young
again this
way oh did I mess
up oh my gosh no no no okay we are good
we are good you still keeping your eyes
open for gargoyles not really Hermione
to be
honest we've got other things to worry
about
at the
moment
and that's right she did start talking
repeatedly about the Gargoyles as soon
as we we need to find Talking gargoyles
for Professor Bin's
homework oh my
goodness
question is how many of those gargoyles
do we have to
find they may have mentioned it at one
point Professor M told us those first
years were somewhere around here there
they
are which way though are they this
way you're Harry Potter did you really
fight he who must not be named and big
snake thing in the second year and win
the tri wizard tournament yeah wow and
Professor mcgonagle told Harry here to
find some snotty nose F who are cheeky
enough not to turn up to her detention
she said if you didn't go then Harry
could feed you all to the dragon that
lives in the kitchens there's not really
a dragon in the kitchens is there want
to find out then hop
[Music]
it I don't remember going hard there F
being in our talk on how to be prefects
yeah well the [__] need to learn a
little
respect dang
Ron letting the power go to his head a
little bit okay so now we should be able
to go back to
mogle oh that's pretty close to where
Dean Thomas is too but he yeah he's the
one who needs the Gargoyles
so and I'm sure Hermione is going to
remind us here
shortly PF scous
scoundrel up
okay you guys think I'm kidding about
the directions no I actually need I need
the footprints every time now I am I am
kind of ignoring them for a second here
because I feel like there's a
gargoyle in here
somewhere I really wish I could shift
the camera around no there's not one in
here I mean you have the ones up here
HOH can we do a little uh incendio on
this no not
that this right
here oh I'm surprised that we can't use
incendio on
those and yet we can do something with
the little house counters over
here
sther
whoops did I just give Slytherin more I
think I
didin Griffin that's kind of
cool I'm not sure why we have the
ability to change it here but
okay did it give us any more that time I
don't think it did Raven
Ravenclaw nah it didn't give us anymore
but just to make sure let's go ahead and
do Hufflepuff as well puff puff
puff make sure it doesn't unlock
anything for doing each of the four
houses looks like it does not so you
know we got to leave it on
Gryffindor that's where we have to leave
[Music]
it all right and apparently
no gargoyles in
here
Professor Umbridge will sort this place
out properly let's walk over here for a
bit come on got to be some out
here what is that
noise o can we light
these yes
indeed also I did learn another thing
from you guys in the comments apparently
the biggest spot where you see the
impact of getting the extra spell damage
is of course in the duels that the duels
are much harder if you don't upgrade a
lot of the Collectibles like we're doing
right now so hopefully we'll be be in
pretty good shape when the time
comes okay anything over here kind of
Hidden Away okay nope all
right I did see a couple more over here
that I think we can
light oh how about you right you don't
know where the other talking gargles are
do you I haven't seen another gargoyle
since the one on that plen disappeared
what happened to him about a year ago
some boy flew through here being chased
by a dragon it knocked my friend right
over the edge uh come back and talk to
me sometime won't you that's pretty good
for a picnic come around anytime it
wasn't your fault Harry do you think
they're all that
mental so wait he doesn't actually count
you marvelous isn't it you could see all
the way to Hogs me if there weren't all
those trees and we were facing the right
way where is hugs me
anyway
incendio
yeah I don't think he
counted level nine let's go all right
Myrtle some new things to see in our
secret room har we get it we don't need
you to tell us every single
time giving us a nice wide shot of
Hogwarts right there
there we got four
more I know this isn't the way I'm
supposed to go but I'm just going to go
on in well actually they are pointing me
in this direction
now o that unlocked something
else okay I got to pay more attention to
the cut
scenes
wait what that's
it maybe there's something else I'm
missing but it looked like it was just
showing me all the Torches have in fact
been lit at this
point all right I did see this book over
here we can examine want to come to the
allery with me no
sorry no I'm trying to read this book a
list of students let's have a
look a list of students let's have a
look that's okay bizarre but oh I see
what we're supposed to mop up now there
a little bit of water right
here
wait where'd it
go thought it was like right where I'm
standing oh let's
move no
okay I thought we were supposed to maybe
put it in the bucket oh wait is this it
right
here right in my yeah I think that's it
okay those students are standing in the
way too not really sure how that's going
to work but we're about to find out
thinker there's a bunch over
here right no all there we go they moved
out of the way
now little bit more right
here
okay all right I think that was it let's
just double check
make sure there's not
another spot over here all
right ticket to see
is hi hey oh my goodness they're
all they're all blocking our
path
ooh so it's all different chest pieces
that we keep finding behind some of
these tapestries
oh man now this is taking me back right
here can I not get in there they did
such a good job with the castle they
really did wi Guardian
Leviosa and if I remember right this is
the one that before the game came out
they actually did a lot of reaching out
to fans and talking with Potter fans to
see what they wanted in the
game and they came so close in some
areas I mean like I said the castle is
really especially for the time it was
built the game was built that is it's
actually pretty
impressive just the game
play the game play just a wee bit
lacking I do I do love the conversations
with students though the little random
comments they make as you walk by no not
the
pulso trying trying a little wingardium
levosa okay that's already been
repaired how about you right
here I realize we're kind of just off
exploring right now instead of really
focusing on our
objective yeah I keep forgetting about
those that's such an easy one feel like
we've passed several of
these let see can you do this on all of
them hi to you
too these actually look pretty flat
right here so maybe
not all right do we go let's go this way
first o that's definitely something
right
there okay back up a little bit
Harry I was about to say I thought it
was
AO all right 185 to the next upgrade oh
and now we're back outside in the
Transfiguration Courtyard okay so let's
just go back through this and now I'm
going to take a right up
here did
you if we could just get past these
other students
here let's see does this one anything we
need to interact
with all right what's inside
here Myrtle's
bathroom no way is she in
here wait can you go in the chamber in
this
game I don't remember
this I don't remember
this no way we can actually go in there
right
oh yeah okay you just unlock some more
of these little mysterious
orbs I was excited for a second thinking
it was going to let us actually go in
there I used to like bubble B all those
pretty
[Applause]
bubbl all right so this takes us back
out into the
courtyard which should take us right
back to
mcgonagal Potter Weasley Miss stranger
once this I hear about dragons in the
kitchens whoops please don't tell first
years like that someone's bound to be
silly enough to believe you and go
looking for them however 10 points to
Gryffindor for
Ingenuity no way she gave us points for
that all right Transfiguration class is
now unlocked let's
go take a little look around the room
here and let's see if her challenge is
similar to flitwick's surely you have
studies to attend to move along wait
we're we're tending to your studies
maybe we have to wait for her to get in
place over there you guys got to move
Harry Ron or excuse me Hermione and Ron
get out of the
way
AO when guardian Leviosa see if we put
this back in place for us for
her come on Harry nope nope nope that's
not gonna work that's not gonna work
come on right
there we tried we tried we actually
tried come on mle you can't be mad at us
now if you remember in the old Chamber
of Secrets game you could get something
with each of these desks right here oh
dude she she's about to get so
mad can I talk to her now and can we
actually do a lesson in here whatever it
is we'll have to wait until later I have
things to do what it said it said uh
Transfiguration class was unlocked
but yeah she she disappeared from here
all right so we're kind of close to
where actually
we're let's do
Sprout and then we'll
save save old seus for
last okay I'm pretty sure that's the
gargoyle we already talked
to the footprints are just a little bit
too slow like see sometimes they just
take off out in front of you like that
it's perfect then other times you're
just standing here waiting on them to
appear there we go now see that's a good
Pace right
there no no luck on that
one wrong way of course I can never
guess the right way I've lost my
timeable
I wonder if these give you
anything the knights nothing
okay all right here's
Sprout Potter Weasley and Miss Granger I
trust you're up to date with your
homework great forget I'm expecting your
essay on self fertilizing shrubs for
tomorrow's lesson and I hope I don't
have to remind you that this is your owl
yeah no professor
Sprout she hopes she didn't have to
remind us as if we could forget every
teacher keeps reminding us every lesson
where are we going to find a book on
self fertilizing shrubs Neville will
explain let's find him come on
Harry okay so we have to talk to Neville
now which I believe he's still in the
room of requirement right
let's go and talk to Snape too we might
as well just get all of the final
objectives that we need did you see
Potter in potions he got another
zero why are we bumping into so many
students in this
playthrough you can't see the
footprints there they go
finally how are you can I someone's out
I hope my PS3 isn't about to die I don't
know if you guys can hear that just
happened a couple seconds ago it's like
this little
popping that is my PS3 Slim it's it's
just right here on the desk beside me
kind of making this popping
noise
occasionally hope it's nothing too
serious we at least got to get to the
end of this playthrough and then
hopefully Half Blood Prince as well by
the way if you guys enjoy these videos
make sure you uh give them a thumbs up
helps more people find them and also I
know these are longer videos so if you
don't have time to watch them all in one
sitting you can hit the I think it's
three little dots down below the bottom
of the video and you can say watch later
you can add it to your basically like a
little playlist that's called watch
later and then if you go back uh it'll
make it easier to go back and watch
it all right so down steps here what are
you doing at the weekend go down to the
lake us I'd like to
busy been in the daily today shut
up shut
up o the music
change the shift in music as we head
into the dungeons there he is ah Potter
after your last feeble attempt at potion
making I expect you to write 12 in of
parchment on the properties of moon
Stone no excuses but I've already got
lots of homework Potter what's going on
with the camera anything less than
acceptable and you will suffer my
displeasure whoa Harry you're oh oh my
oh no oh boy what have we
done what have we done no Snape he's
this is all he's doing I know
it
I don't even know I'm so distracted by
what by what's happening right now I
don't even know what he
said oh this is bad guys this is really
bad we're we're legitimately stuck
here no please don't be
gamebreaking please don't be
gamebreaking I'm trying to just maneuver
around for but there's no there's no
roll there's no jump in this game I am
holding the button to run fast I mean
the only thing you can do isard Leos
maybe that'll help us
no okay here's what we're going to try
I'm going to do a I'm going to do
save because of the fact that it always
put you back in the room of
requirement I'm hoping that we'll be
good okay good news it did put us back
in the room of requirement says we have
two tasks to
complete and because Neville's already
here we can just go ahead and knock that
one
out and then hopefully Snape's Quest
isn't bugged or something do you know
anything about self fertilizing shrubs
of course I've got a book flesh eating
trees of the world which has got some
really good pictures of them it's on my
bedside table in the boys's dmetry if
you want to borrow it
thanks another fetch Quest I know you
guys are so
surprised I know you guys are so so
surprised
oh man Gryffindor boys dormatory let's
go fortunately it's not too far from
here all right so one thing I have
noticed is it seems like hermy only
talks about the
Gargoyles when we're actually close to
one
which
means that there's got to be one in this
grand staircase somewhere cuz almost
every time that we pass through here oh
right there she talks about
it okay Gryffindor common room here we
are oh my goodness I forgot they
actually put the flying snitch in this
game too I wonder if Hogwarts Legacy
took uh you'd like to play chest with me
inspiration from that you can be
wise
I forgot this was a thing I legit forgot
this was a thing win a game of wizard
chess against the Gryffindor
Champion do we actually is it is it
actual
chess
[Music]
wait okay so right stick lets
me
dude this is
crazy oh my goodness I haven't played
chess in so
long this is going to be really bad guys
I'm warning you this
is this could potentially be very bad a
few moments
later stalemate stalemate
what how do we not win that we go again
one eternity
later
Checkmate
yes yes and congratulations to Ronald
Weasley for the greatest played game of
chess wow that should not have been that
hard
but hey we won and we're moving on wow
okay man I can't even remember what we
were here for
exactly okay hold on we talked to
Neville it was a book right yeah it was
a book that Neville said was up in his
room let me see are we this
way okay there's Trevor I
assume
incendio
Depo all right where is the
book okay well if Trevor
is if this is where there we go wait
what I love this thing put on the
invisibility cloak this will get me past
anyone I didn't even remember this was a
thing oh my
goodness so can we that was fun C can we
use that
anytime I guess we can did the game ever
tell me about that and I just missed it
you guys world did I completely miss
that at some point essay uh herione
could you help me with the opening
paragraph oh all right
then and so therefore and they and in
conclusion all right finally right let's
take these essays back to Professor
Sprout back to Professor Sprout okay so
Professor Sprout is still there as is
Snape I don't even know what Snape
wanted we're going to have to talk to
him
again see if we can't figure out what's
going on
there
well don't you like Secrets I've got
lots oh my goodness Myrtle relax with
the secrets okay just relax we get it we
get
it
[Music]
Dragon's egg pass friend to
hlep
[Music]
all right Sprout we made it back
Professor Sprout we've brought you our
essays on self fertilizing shrubs
excellent
work superb diagrams as well 10 points
to Gryffindor well if you have time to
spend on your herbology as owl students
you're welcome to use the
green okay so what is
that are you going to teach us something
do we need to do something like flick
Wick with you or come in come in here to
revise herbology are you nice I don't
know why mogal wouldn't let us do
anything this crop of mandres is ready
for reporting guardium Leviosa will do
the trick repotting man man quickly you
can do it Mr Potter off you go there
it's like the staple herbology lesson
you know doesn't matter which game it
is now the question is oh before it
wakes
up I'm wondering if she's judging us on
speed I really hope
[Music]
not because if she's judging it based on
speed then we'll have to do it much
faster next
time quickly put this into
his before it wakes
up oh no I thought we messed that one up
oh round
two what excuse
me I didn't really mean to for that one
but it
works this one no no no no no right here
leosa didn't they just grab them in the
m in the books in the movie no no no no
no goodness this ridiculous lock on
feature man well unfortunately our hard
drive started to get full so it cut off
that recording however we only got an
acceptable which you know for us is not
acceptable so we're going to do it again
here and I can only assume is ready for
reporting how quickly you can do it I
mean they're all about the speed here
let's see how you go then all right
we're ready I'm just going
to
[Music]
quickly like I just don't feel like
again the com I mean not combat the
controls they're just so sluggish I
don't know it's never clear when I can
actually move on to the next one see I
think that one's just I think it's just
going to go like once
we let go I think it's I think it's fine
I think we can immediately move over to
the next one if only the lock on was a
little bit more consistent but like like
just drop it drop
it all right round
two got to use L2 and R2 much more to
like quickly switch between
them I don't know where I need to take
this guy right here
but maybe this
one and then you over here come
on just take you back right there drop
it drop it drop it drop it Harry my
goodness okay let's start on this
side drop
you drop
you come on grab
him Harry do the spell do the spell oh
my goodness why is he not doing the
spell got to get just the right one
movement
all right come on give me an O give me
an O for that you have a good grasp of
hered expectations exceeds expectations
I'll take it but how in the world do you
get an outstanding on that sheesh that's
got to be tough and I assume we could
just go back and redo these until you
get all the way to outstanding but we
are done with everything oh my goodness
except Dean Thomas that's the Gargoyles
the ptil twins
I really want to see if we can figure
that one out before we wrap up today
because it felt like they wanted me to
teach them something if I remember
correctly and
yet they're not in the room of
requirement so let's see where are the
footprints going back this
way and then right here oh that's right
I think it was something in
divination so we're going to have to go
all the way up to the to
Tower possibly run into trani up here
okay wait there they are you ready to
come to the meeting we haven't been in
yet that toad Umbridge is in there with
Professor tone Umbridge has had it in
for Professor Tone ever since that
stupid inspection she did you can't suck
me I've oh so they moved it up here in
the game Hogwarts is my
home instead of it taking place in front
of
[Music]
everyone wait you should have seen this
coming looks like your divination class
has been cancelled poor Professor tone
can't in for the DA meeting anything to
show that UMB woman that's all we needed
to do for
that oh my goodness you have 27 out of
28 da members in the room of requirement
so the only one we still need is our boy
Dean so we have to find all all of the
Gargoyles and I have no idea how many
there are that's kind of the confusing
part about this is we don't know how
many we're after right now and really
all I know to do keeping your open
for Hermione yes yes I am I am indeed
but all I know what to do is I think we
can go ahead and Mark let's mark Snape
and let's go ahead and try and Tackle
what we have to do for him and hopefully
fingers crossed c as we're doing that
we'll run into a couple more of
these because it certainly doesn't seem
like they're forget we need all over the
place homework I know Hermione I
know if you would like to point out
where some I'd be happy to head that
way I definitely would all right back
down here with Snape and I'm going to be
extra careful this time amazement to me
Potter I didn't think even you could
continue such a miserable record of
academic
failure oh Potter whilst you have aely
demonstrated that you cannot read
instructions I expect you to at least be
able to listen to them I'm sorry Snape
last time you cast some spell upon me
that let's check in the library put me
in the torch okay now thank you that's
drafts and Potions that's being useful
hermion let's go potion section of the
library but first I want to take a look
at everything else down here
anything else we can do oh there's
another portrait
here that one's just sleeping though I
do see something
to all I can think about is that my
father's getting me tickets to see
Island
play get lost poter
ooh that one had a little torch in front
of it well did the other one not I
thought the other one did
too oh another one of these wardian
levosa hey this is uh the Bloody Baron I
believe
right okay so that one's probably top
left this one's going to be top right I
think she needs someone to shut her
up nice it automatic
flips it
around okay that one should go right
here come on Harry oh is it because
they're standing on it I wish I could be
come on guys i' make a great beater
don't you
think oh and there he is
too
thanks now I've really got the
creeps discovered a new house
ghost actually we discovered all of them
right there things to show you in our
secret room you don't have to bring the
others if you don't want
to oh my goodness
Myrtle a little too strong just a bit
IGN them
har
that's got to be an incendio right there
incendio
nice thanks now I've really got the
creeps okay is there anything we can
do
depulso
h a little bit surprised I'm guessing
there's something in here that I'm not
interacting with that you're probably
supposed
to but for now I think we're just going
to go on and head to the
library okay now to find the book maybe
it's in the back
here oh no don't tell me it's in the
Restricted
Section
what
oh you can just
walk you can just walk right through all
right I don't know if we're supposed to
be sneaking around here or not
but dude where is the
book
usually there's like a a little mini cut
scene or something that plays kind of
pointing it out to
you but I don't see anything the
library's on the second
floor Ron we need to check the shelves
in the potion section where's the potion
section
Hermione let's check in the library oh
my
gosh okay potion section I mean maybe
that has like a cauldron or something
[Music]
nearby how would you be able to
tell what the section
is everything looks the same in
here everything looks the same
[Music]
dude how about right here I think a Mion
would spend a holiday oh my gosh I'm not
talking to you
guys I'm just trying to interact with
all of
these dude you have to be kidding me
this is
crazy oh maybe it is in the restricted
[Music]
part going to have to go through every
single row
here this is the book we need oh look
moonstone is sometimes known as the
wishing St um H oh no you have to write
this finally but I suppose I could
correct it for
you dude no indications at all and of
where you're supposed to go
conclusion
okay so let's take these essays back to
Professor now we have to go all the way
back down to the
dungeons I still don't understand why we
didn't have anything to do with megon
snake I've brought you my moones
indeed let us see if you can
differentiate between Monk's hood and
Moonstone shall
we I suppose this is
acceptable follow me but I must remind
you Potter you will not be able to rely
on Miss Granger when you take your
owl the potions class is now
unlocked oh Myrtle's got you've not
visit got more secrets for us for a long
time you should see what's in there
now oh we can't go in that little area
all right let's see if we have a Potter
make sure you don't waste my
time begin oh wait what to lift the
correctly color potions Into The
Cauldron
okay wi Guardian
Leviosa okay now
green dude it is really difficult to
tell which
one you have
selected
come on
drop the good news is it seems like you
can kind of let go anywhere in the
general area above it and it will fall
in nope put it
back
my goodness when guardium
Leviosa okay so it starts basically at a
zero
right in the middle and then I can press
L2 twice I think there we go and then
that will select the yellow
one and so if it was like that green one
it would be R2 three times send it
work surprisingly you have earned an
outstanding let's go remember that you
will have to do your exam alone let's go
our first outstanding and ironically it
is in potions with our boy Prof
Professor Snape how about that he did
not seem happy about it either oh he
seemed so annoyed okay the final one we
need is Dean Thomas and all of the
Gargoyles I believe we only had one so
far that counted we tried talking to
this one right
here and yeah he he couldn't help us
with anything really and what's funny is
I feel like I've seen a bunch of those
as I've been playing the game but now
when it gets to this moment I I can't
find any so we know we have the one for
sure oh wait is that one up there I
think there's a talking gargoyle
somewhere near here let's go dude let's
go now this is the area where we were
having to help out Colin and his camera
but it looks like it everything has
gotten messed up
again let's go and repair that and then
I think I saw it sitting right up here
is that not one oh great how about you
no okay it's probably going to be one we
have to climb for isn't
it right here
maybe no we can't talk to any of
these there's there's definitely some I
was about to say I know there's
something at the end we're looking for
talking goggles can you you uh talk yes
great glad you think so can I ask you a
question are you happy with your
position in life no I'm not I'd much
rather be South Facey let's go maybe I
should talk to someone see if we can get
him moved yeah we could stick him in
um's office wait could we actually Ser
right might be a bit cruel to the gargo
though three down two to go three down
two to go all right so I guess that one
did Count or there's been one that I
forgot about so that's we only need two
more let's see if herione will give me a
hint how many goles do you have to find
for five well we already found three
don't forget we need to tell Dean where
yeah sure maybe if we go tell Dean now
then he'll give us a little hint where
the rest
are so so far I'm pretty sure that
they've all been
outside so possibly they're all going to
be outside I'm going to make a loop all
the way
around you know what Transfiguration
we're back here let's see if mogal has
anything for us to do whatever it is
we'll have to wait nope she
doesn't where is the
gargoyle
oh my
goodness I was just randomly wandering
please uh are you a talking gargoyle
knock knock who's there Twi twit who
sorry didn't realize you were an
owl
are all the Gargoyles mental no don't go
wa so that counts right how many left
now one right one we only need to find
one more yes one more all right so maybe
we're heading on the right track oh so
that one was just right there on the way
up all right let's go all the way
up see if we spot any now that one was
inside okay so there goes our theory
about that here's defense against the
dark arts get there are lots of new
things to see in our secret rooms oh
that was for visiting all known did it
say secret rooms I
think what does this
do
Depo
AO okay I I I have to stay focused on
the Gargoyles but
clearly there's something to find here
if we come oh this should be an incendio
right incendio
yeah can we actually go inside here nope
we cannot
denied and we only need 20 of the orbs
to upgrade go to the next level oh
that's got to be a
depulso nothing for it
though nothing at
all all right so let's just go back down
so evidently we haven't even been in
this area of the castle yet since we
just discovered that plus we just found
that gargoyle right there so let's just
keep heading
down ooh I love that window that's
pretty awesome right there Hi
hi this Castle definitely feels more
like a replica of what they did in the
movies like there are several locations
where you can just point to it looking
exactly like it did in the
films all right where's this going to
take us back outside ooh suspension
bridge okay this looks like a good place
for a
gargoyle oh come
on
nowhere wait wait wait wait
wait okay we've definitely been here cuz
that was for nearly headless
Nick gargoyle anywhere
anywhere let's go up instead of down
let's check floor number
four
anything we can do in
here imagine if we just guessed right
first try first
try I'm not even going to talk to you
cuz I know you're not going to help
us ooh okay wait this leads
outside bye oh this is this is promising
excuse me can you talk but you just did
no I didn't and who did she did that one
there the one with the bushy hair my
hair is not bushy that's got to be it
Ron is is my hair bushy no well only a
bit it's been windy I've been busy I
promise you
guys let's get back until yes it may
have been more tedious without using a
guide but ladies and gentlemen we did
it now we've got to go back to Dean let
me go ahead and Mark him actually he may
still be marked
and then all of the tasks will be
complete which I'm thinking will trigger
the next main mission for the
game back to the Transfiguration
Courtyard here we are Dean what is up
dude hey Dean we found all those
gargoyles oh cool can I copy them down
in the dmat Tre later you'd better ask a
m if that's all right of course after
the DA meeting cool see you later let's
see what happens now you have met 28 out
of
28 requirements I know that's not
exactly what the sentence said same
thing though same thing let's see if we
have any tasks at all Cho Chang wants to
learn levoc Corpus I'm assuming that is
going to be inside the room of
requirement and thus our next big task
for the game which makes this an
excellent point to stop this video guys
I really hope you're enjoying the series
make sure to give it a thumbs up if you
made it all the way to the end to today
if you made it to the end of the video
how about you put a broomstick as a
comment down below put a broomstick to
let me know you made it all the way here
to the end of the video as always thank
you all so much for watching and I'll
talk to you again soon